es geht jetzt um den Tagesordnungspunkt
Stärkung der Bundespolizei es liegt vor
ein Antrag der Fraktion der cdu/csu sie
möchte dass die Bundespolizei weiter
gestärkt wird bekanntermaßen braucht sie
mehr Personal bessere Bezahlung
zeitgemäße handlungsbefugnisse und
Unionsfraktion argumentiert hierzu
insbesondere vor dem Hintergrund des
Kriegs Russlands gegen die Ukraine
dieser Krieg habe nicht nur
außenpolitische folgen sondern erhöhe
auch die innenpolitische Bedrohung in
Deutschland gezielte Sabotage Akte
könnte es geben insbesondere gegen im
kritische Infrastrukturen es gibt eine
ansteigende Anzahl illegaler
Grenzübertritte sagt die Unionsfraktion
Bedrohung durch Extremismus und
Islamismus so wie der Kampf gegen
Kleinigkeit klar Kriminalität spielten
auch noch eine wichtige Rolle so wie
gesagt der Antrag der oder im Antrag der
Unionsfraktion es gibt übrigens auch ein
Gesetzentwurf zu diesem aber aus der
Ampelkoalition das wird hier hin und
wieder anklicken aber zunächst Michael
Brandt für die Unionsfraktion sie
verteidigt gegen Extremismus von rechts
und links gegen Islamismus Clan
Kriminalität gegen Chaoten Hooligans
oder gewaltbereite Einzeltäter ihr
Einsatz ist zudem unverzichtbar zum
Schutz unserer Außengrenzen und im Namen
der cdu/csu und sicherlich auch im Namen
des ganzen Hauses möchte ich dafür den
Polizistinnen und Polizisten im Einsatz
den Respekt des ganzen deutschen
Bundestages aussprechen
Innenminister der Union haben die größte
Modernisierung und Stärkung der
Bundespolizei ihre Geschichte
verantwortet es wurden allein von 2017
bis 2021 über 8.000 neue Stellen
geschaffen die Besoldung und die
Polizeizulage verbessert und die
Bundespolizei auf insgesamt 54.000
Personen gestärkt heute müssen wir
feststellen die erste
spd-innenministerin dreht die Zeit
zurück die Bundespolizei wird wieder auf
Kante genäht Personal wird abgebaut
2023 hören Sie zu kommt ist zu einer
Personalkürzung um 1,5 Prozent in der
Verwaltung obwohl es seit 2016 einen
aufwuchs an Einsatzkräften von über 30
Prozent gab liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das kann in keiner Organisation
funktionieren wenn sie der Opposition
nicht glauben dann hören sie auf die
Gewerkschaft
die versprochene ruhegehaltsfähigkeit
Frau Feser Fehlanzeige bis heute nichts
passiert
it-gestützter Grenzschutz Stichwort
Smartphone die aktuellen Mittel im
Haushalt sind unzureichen um selbst die
eigenen eu-verpflichtungen einzuhalten
und obwohl wir wegen des massiven
Anstiegs von Migration dringend weiteres
Personal an unseren Grenzen benötigen
wird dies verweigert von zehn
Einsatzhundertschaften zur Unterstützung
völlig überlasteter Beamten hat Frau
Feser gerade mal vier bewilligt kein
Wunder dass angesichts dieser
Entwicklung und der Enttäuschung selbst
junge Beamte inzwischen über den
Ausstieg aus der Bundespolizei
nachdenken ich habe diese Telefonate
diese Woche geführt mit Beamten die an
der Grenze im Einsatz sind das sind
alarmierende ja besorgniserregende
Anzeichen
und besorgniserregendes auch dass nun
ausgerechnet die verantwortliche
Ministerin die Anerkennung der Realität
verweigert ja sogar davon spricht dass
es gar keine migrationskrise gäbe hier
im Deutschen Bundestag am 24 November
wenn sie von der Bundespolizei an der
Grenze Länder und bis hin zu den
Kommunen alle so massiv im Stich lassen
die hier an die an den Rand der
Belastungsgrenze kommen schaden sie
unserem Gemeinwesen
sie wollen wie wir Extremismus bekämpfen
dann bitte achten Sie darauf keine
Anlässe zur Erstarkung von Extremismus
zu liefern stärken wir gemeinsam
diejenigen die mit der doppelten
Migration aus der Ukraine und auch aus
anderen Ländern vor gewaltigen
Herausforderungen stehen lassen Sie
unser Land in dieser Lage nicht im Stich
eine moderne Bundespolizei braucht ein
modernen Rahmen für Ihre Arbeit für
diesen Rahmen legen wir als cdu/csu
heute einen umfassenden Antrag vor mit
konkreten Vorschlägen dazu zählen
erstens ausreichendes Personal zweitens
moderne Ausstattung und drittens sehr
wichtig zeitgemäße Befugnisse und
Zuständigkeiten zur effektiven
Verbrechensbekämpfung und
Strafverfolgung organisierte
Kriminalität ist ein ganz komplexes
Phänomen Rauschgift Geldwäsche
Waffenhandel Menschenhandel liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen statt kleinster
gemeinsamer Nenner in der Ampel statt
Blockaden braucht es Reformen statt
Lehrer Worte und Entwürfe einen großen
Entwurf
in der letzten Koalition hatten wir
gemeinsam erreicht dass der Bundestag
eine breite Modernisierung des
bundespolizeigesetzes von 1994 auf den
Weg brachte niemand konnte erwarten dass
die abgestimmten Kompromisse im
Bundesrat auf der Zielgerade gekippt
würden die diese Blockade bleibt eine
große fehlerleistung und auch ein
Schaden für die innere Sicherheit
unseres Landes umso wichtiger bleibt es
einen neuen Anlauf zu Unternehmen im
Ringen mit den Ländern dürfen nicht
wieder Kompetenzstreit oder Ideologien
notwendige Reformen für die
Bundespolizei und innere Sicherheit
blockieren und vor diesem Hintergrund
ist es falsch und auch politisch feige
Frau Ministerin Fezer ein ziemlich
inhaltslehr-entwurf für ein Gesetz
vorzulegen der nur minimale Anpassungen
beinhaltet und aus dem die Angst vor den
notwendigen Reformen spricht es kann ja
sein dass die hessische Wahlkämpferin
ein schnelles Gesetz will selbst ohne
Substanz aber das hilft der
Bundespolizei nicht
Kompetenzen bei Cyberangriffen kein Wort
und gefährlich auch nach dem Anschlag
auf den Berliner Weihnachtsmarkt vor
genau sechs Jahren dem brutalen Fall
Amri soll die Bundespolizei auch weiter
keine Haft zur Sicherung der Abschiebung
vornehmen können liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Ampel das darf so nicht
bleiben
nicht Zaghaftigkeit sondern Mut brauchen
die Reform gerade in so einer unsicheren
Zeit lassen Sie uns die Bundespolizei
diesen wichtigen Pfeiler unserer
Demokratie gemeinsam stärken
Michael Brandt für die Unionsfraktion
zum Antrag der Unionsfraktion zur
Stärkung der Bundespolizei und dazu
spricht jetzt Uli Grötsch aus der
SPD-Fraktion der warmer Polizeibeamter
bevor er in den Bundestag kam
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen lassen Sie mich
am Anfang dieser Debatte eine Sache
sagen die für sehr wichtig heute aus uns
allersicht lassen Sie uns in Zeiten wie
diesen nicht ist Sicherheitsbehörden
instrumentalisieren lassen Sie die
Sicherheitsbehörden raus aus
parteipolitischen Spielchen tragen Sie
nicht den hessischen Landtagswahlkampf
in den Deutschen Bundestag schon gar
nicht wenn es um unsere
Sicherheitsbehörden geht wir haben alle
gesehen dass das Thema dafür dass die
Zeiten dafür viel zu ernst sind denn und
das wissen sie alle auch wenn sie es
womöglich in der folgenden Debatte
negieren werden sie alle wissen dass
keine Behörde des Bundes und somit auch
keine Sicherheitsbehörde in den letzten
Jahren einen so großen aufwuchs erfahren
hat wie das bei der Bundespolizei der
Fall war und ich sage zu liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Herausforderungen werden größer ja für
ja für alle Sicherheitsbehörden und
damit natürlich auch für die
Bundespolizei und das ist mir wichtig zu
sagen
diese aufwuchs war der Beginn eines
Weges einer Entwicklung die auch in der
Zukunft ihre Fortsetzung finden wird und
auf dem als nächstes und sehr zeitnah
die Schaffung eines modernen
Rechtsrahmens für die Bundespolizei
steht ein neues bundespolizeigesetz
und
lassen Sie mich das an die Adresse der
bundesinnenministerin sagen ich bin froh
und dankbar darüber Frau Ministerin dass
Sie wissen welche zentrale Rolle die
Bundespolizei im sicherheitsgefüge der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland einnimmt und
und das ist ja sogar noch wichtiger dass
sie auch entsprechend handeln Frau
Ministerin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen dass es vor allem in Zeiten wie
diesen von elementarer Wichtigkeit und
ich sage schon auch an die Adresse des
Antragstellers sie hatten 16 Jahre lang
Zeit so lange hatten sie das
Bundesinnenministerium geführt sie
hatten mehr als genug Zeit das alles
umzusetzen was sie ihren in ihrem Antrag
noch mal aufgeschrieben haben als wohl
eine Art Revival wenn man so möchte ich
sage ihnen seien sie auch froh darüber
dass sie in den Jahren 2013 bis 2021 in
der großen Koalition der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion an ihrer Seite
hat Events um die Bundespolizei geht ich
nimm Dich beim nächsten Satz
ausdrücklich aus lieber Michael Brandt
aber man hat schon gemerkt
dass Ihr Verständnis für die
Bundespolizei ein sehr wackliches ist
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
wir werden hier in Kürze den neuen
Entwurf für das bundespolizeigesetz für
ein Update des Rechtsrahmens wenn man so
möchte denen es übrigens das wissen
einige und schreibe 1994
unverändert zu gibt beraten und sie alle
sind gerne aufgefordert im Gesetz dann
zuzustimmen und sich somit mit uns mit
der Ampelkoalition auf den Weg zu machen
und ich sage Ihnen auch mehr als 50.000
Beschäftigte bei der Bundespolizei
würden es wohl gut finden
Gesetz nicht gestritten und polemisiert
wird so wie sie es eben versucht haben
und so glaube ich in der Debatte auch
noch weiter tun werden sondern wenn sie
sich ich sag's noch mal gerade in Zeiten
wie diesen alle hinter ihren
Sicherheitsbehörden versammeln und für
Sie arbeiten denn ohne sicher ohne
Bundespolizei ist Sicherheit in
Deutschland nicht denkbar dafür können
wir alle jeden Beschäftigten
dort dankbar sein und ganz aktuell wir
wissen das für die Arbeit bei der
Enttarnung des Rechts Reichsbürger
terror-netzwerkes 450
bundespolizistinnen und Polizisten haben
letzte Woche zum gelingendes Anti
terroreinsatzes beigetragen das war
team-work der Sicherheitsbehörden vom
allerfeinsten und das wird auch noch ein
eine Weile weitergehen dieses Teamwork
in der Auswertung der Daten wir haben
das am Montag in der Sondersitzung des
Innenausschusses gehört hat ja erst
begonnen und ich bin gespannt
was da noch alles zum Vorschein kommt
und wer noch alles zum Vorschein kommt
im Zuge der weiteren Ermittlungen und
auch welchen Gruppierungen und am Ende
Parteien diese Leute angehören werden
wir
haben auch im Haushalt 2023 die
Bundespolizei weiter gestärkt zu
bekommen die Bundespolizei zum Beispiel
1000 neue Stellen um die Anwärterinnen
und Anwärter auch übernehmen zu können
das Bundeskriminalamt wächst weiter auf
um 180 Stellen zur Bekämpfung von
organisierter Kriminalität und
Extremismus und das alles trotz
auslaufender Corona konjunkturmittel und
ich glaube wir sind uns alle einig das
ist die richtige
Prioritätensetzung für die Zukunft
dazu gehört aber auch liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen dass wir alles dafür tun
die schwarzen Schafe unter denen also
diejenigen die nicht auf dem Boden des
Grundgesetzes stehen die das Negative
Potenzial haben den Ruf der ganzen
Behörde zu gefährden dass wir alles
dafür tun Verfassungsfeinde aus dem
Staatsdienst zu entfernen und zwar
schnell und konsequent
wir
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen lassen
Sie mich am Ende sagen unsere Polizei
ein genießen in Deutschland zu Recht
sehr hohes Ansehen das hat eine aktuelle
Erhebung des Bundeskriminalamtes wieder
ergeben in der über 80 Prozent der
Befragten sagen dass sie den Polizeien
in Deutschland Vertrauen auch das zeigt
uns wir sind auf einem guten Weg und
deshalb auch wenn Ihr Antrag zur glaube
ich so nehme ich ihnen war er wohl als
schaufensterantrag kurz vor Weihnachten
gedacht ist wir brauchen ihn nicht das
wissen Sie wir lehnen in auch deshalb ab
vielen Dank
aus der SPD-Fraktion in der Debatte zum
Antrag der Unionsfraktion zur Stärkung
der Bundespolizei der nächste Redner ist
Steffen ja nicht aus der AFD Fraktion
auch er war Polizeibeamter bevor er in
den Bundestag kam
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
die Bundespolizei nicht politisch zu
instrumentalisieren wir nehmen Sie und
die Regierung immer wieder gerne
die Beschäftigung mit der inneren
Sicherheit darf für die Politik niemals
zum Selbstzweck werden vor fast sechs
Jahren am 19 dezember 2016
tötet der Polizei und
nachrichtendienstlich bekannte die
islamistische Attentäter Anis Amri auf
dem Berliner Breitscheidplatz insgesamt
13 Menschen und verletzt ist 67 Personen
solche Kräutern dürfen sich nie wieder
wiederholen in drei Tagen werden wir
wieder in angemessener Form der Opfer
dieser schrecklichen Tat gedenken ich
bin in Gedanken bei den verwandten der
Opfer
ein unverzichtbarer Bestandteil zum
Schutz der öffentlichen Sicherheit aber
tatsächlich auch zum Schutz der
nationalen Grenzen der Schienenwege
unter Flughäfen ist unsere Bundespolizei
circa
54.000 Mitarbeiter sind in diesem
Bereich tätig von 2017 bis 2021 haben
sich die Planstellen bei der
Bundespolizei von 42.000 auf ca 50.000
Stellen erhöht der jährliche Haushalt in
selben Zeitraum von 3,3 Milliarden Euro
auf 4,7 Milliarden ist angehoben worden
jeder einzelne Cent den wir für unsere
Bundespolizei investiert haben ist gut
angelegtes Geld für die Zukunft
Deutschlands die Bundespolizei muss auch
zukünftig weiter gestärkt und ausgebaut
werden
aber es bleibt nach wie vor viel zu tun
als Abgeordneter habe ich mich in den
sitzungsfreien Wochen mehrfach zu den
Polizeidienststellen
Polizeidienststellen aufgesucht und mich
mit dienststellenleitern und Beamten des
Polizeivollzugsdienstes unterhalten
hierbei sprechen
so fleißig sind wir hierbei konnte ich
mir ein eigenes Bild zu den
Gegebenheiten und in Anforderungen im
täglichen Abläufen bei der Bundespolizei
machen einzelne Schwerpunkte sind dabei
immer wieder zur Sprache gekommen zur
Bekämpfung der schleuserkriminalität und
zur Ahndung der 31 Straftaten sollten
die Beamten zukünftig möglich sein auch
außerhalb der 30 Kilometer Zone im
gesamten Bundesgebiet eigenständig
ermitteln zu dürfen auch die
entsaftbearbeitung bei der von der
Bundespolizei zuerst festgestellten
Straftaten ist ein wichtiger Beitrag und
behördliche Ressourcen zu bündeln die
derzeit noch gängige Praxis eine
Strafakte quasi für die
Staatsanwaltschaft komplett
vorzubereiten um sie dann die
Landespolizei zu übergeben widerspricht
modernen
effektivitätsgrundsätzen hier müssen
dringend rechtliche Rahmenbedingungen
geändert werden
die Privatisierung der Autobahn hat
insbesondere in Grenzregionen dazu
geführt dass die Einrichtung von
größeren Kontrollstellen nicht mehr
unangekündigt möglich ist sondern zuvor
bei der privaten Betreibergesellschaft
angemeldet werden muss die darauf
folgenden stauanzeigen auf den
Navigationsgeräten der Fahrzeuge leiten
den zu kontrollierenden Verkehr dann
regelmäßig in andere Kontrollstelle
vorbei ein Überraschungseffekt wird hier
durch deutlich eingeschränkt es bräuchte
auch vermehrt sogenannte
verkehrstrichter um die Geschwindigkeit
des fahrverkehrs auf derartigen
Kontrollen des Verkehrs auf das Autobahn
zu verlangsamen eine solche
Mittelbeschaffung wäre ein wichtiger
Beitrag zum Arbeitsschutz unserer
eingesetzten Beamten
bei länger eingerichteten
Kontrollstellen beispielsweise auf
Autobahnen benötigen die Beamten
insbesondere in kalten Wintertagen aber
auch zum Schutz vor Regen und Nässe
mobile Kontrollstellen Ausstattungen
praxisbezogene Bedarfe sind da
beispielsweise sogenannte agrarzelte
welche die als Überdachung als für
Kontrollen von Reisebussen erforderlich
sind damit die Fahrgäste und Beamten bei
Wind und Wetter nicht im Freien stehen
summa summarum benötigt die
Bundespolizei zukünftig vermehrt Lage
angepasste Einsatzmittel um
Arbeitsweisen optimieren zu können
eines der größten Probleme in
Dienstalltag der Bundespolizei bleibt
aber die viel zu geringe Zahl an
Rückführung von Personen die sich
unerlaubt in Deutschland aufhalten im
Jahr 2021 waren
33.6.600 Rückführung von Ausländern
vorgesehen allerdings wurden davon nur
die Hälfte also rund 15.000
Rückführungen auch wirklich vollzogen
und der Jahresbericht der Bundespolizei
sagt aus für die Diskrepanz an
Rückführung war hauptursächlich dass die
zur Abschiebung vorgesehenen Personen
der Bundespolizei am Flugtag nicht
Zurückführung übergeben werden konnten
hier müssten sie Frau Innenministerin
ansetzen und endlich eine wirksame
abschiebe Offensive einleiten anstatt
ihre Energie bei der Jagd auf
phantombedrohung zu verschwenden
während die im Jahr 2021 im
Zuständigkeitsbereich der
Bundesregierung festgestellten
Straftaten in vielen Bereichen
rückläufig waren lagen die größten
Zunahmen in den Bereichen Betrug und bei
den Verstößen gegen das
Aufenthaltsgesetz ich sage sage uns
schreibe
171.000 Verstöße gegen das
Aufenthaltsgesetz hat allein die
Bundesregierung im Jahr 2021
festgestellt dies ist nicht zuletzt auf
die Politik der offenen Grenzen unsere
Bundesregierung zurückzuführen
leider schweigt sich der Antrag der CDU
dazu aus wie sie die genaue
Zuständigkeitsverteilung bei der
Strafverfolgung durch Land und Bund
voneinander abgrenzen wollen eine
Doppelzuständigkeit von Bundes- und
Landespolizei zur Durchführung eines
strafprozessualen Ermittlungsverfahren
etwa bei Tagen die ein Bahnhöfen
begangen werden würden zu einem
unüberschaubaren behördenchaos führen
das Thema Strafverfolgung ist aber zu
bedeutend als dass man es hier
schaufensterartig in nur drei Zeilen
abschließend darstellen könnte zum
Schluss sei noch gesagt Beamte und
insbesondere Polizeibeamte die mit die
Recht und Gesetz verpflichtet sind und
nicht den politischen politischen
Fantasien der jeweiligen Regierung
unterliegen dürfen nicht nur die
Bundespolizisten gehören vor den
Generalverdacht geschützt sondern auch
neue Bewerber für den
Polizeivollzugsdienst einen weiteren
politischen gesinnungstift von Nancy
faces Gnaden lehnen wir entschieden ab
ich wünsche allen deutschen einen
friedlichen vierten Advent und frohe
Weihnachten
[Applaus]
nächste Redner für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen Marcel Emmerich
Marcel Emmerich ist Obmann im
Innenausschuss des Bundestags
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren
zum Antrag der Union will ich zunächst
sagen das Ansehen die Bundespolizei zu
stärken und zu unterstützen das teilen
wir natürlich die Angehörigen der
Sicherheitsbehörden insgesamt und der
Bundespolizei im speziellen die rund um
die Uhr für Sicherheit sorgen und uns
bei der Verteidigung der freiheitlich
demokratischen Grundordnung unterstützen
verdienen Respekt und Anerkennung und
das war für die Bundespolizei mit Blick
auf das 50-jährige Jubiläum der GSG 9 an
dieser Stelle nochmal herzlichen
Glückwunsch dem Einsatz beim G7 Gipfel
in ellmauern der bundesweiten Razzia
gegen die Reichsbürger letzte Woche und
der normalen
Arbeitszeit im normalen Arbeitsalltag
ein mehr als ereignisreiches Jahr vielen
Dank an die Polizistinnen und Polizisten
für die professionelle Arbeit und das
hohe Engagement
zu den wichtigsten Aufgaben einer guten
Innenpolitik gehört das die Sicherheit
der Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu
gewährleisten um Gefahren abzuwehren und
Straftaten verfolgen zu können muss die
Polizei folgerichtig handlungsfähig
aufgestellt sein es braucht dafür vor
allem gute technische Ausstattung und
genug Personal und dafür sorgen wir auch
als Ampelkoalition konkret zum Beispiel
personell mit einem kontinuierlichen
Stellen zu stellen Zuwachs für die
nächsten Jahre technisch nehmen wir Geld
in die Hand für Boote und neue Drohnen
damit stärken wir ganz konkret die
Arbeit für die Bundespolizei
wenn man sich ihren Antrag dann weiter
anschaut Liebe Union dann stellt man
fest dass es vor allem ein Katalog
voller Gesetzesverschärfung ist nichts
haben sie ausgelassen Quellen TKÜ online
Durchsuchungen Gesichtserkennung
Wohnraumüberwachung ohne jede Balance
wie ohne jede Balance da bleibt wirklich
kein Schäfchen trocknen
und das ist problematisch denn wenn wir
über die Polizei reden dann reden wir
vor allem immer auch über das Verhältnis
zwischen zwischen Staat und Gesellschaft
zwischen Bürgerinnen und Bürgern und dem
Staat und dabei gilt es nun mal die
Grundrechte gegen unverhältnismäßige
Eingriffe des Staates zu schützen wir
leben in einem der sichersten Länder
dieser Welt in dem es zugleich die
Freiheit des Einzelnen so gering gilt
wie möglich einzuschränken diese Balance
aufrecht zu halten ist unser Ziel und es
geht immer noch der Grundsatz immer
schärfere Gesetze für nicht automatisch
zu mehr Sicherheit und deswegen ist es
elementar jede Maßnahme auch
Verhältnismäßigkeit auf Wirksamkeit und
rechtfertigkeit zu prüfen und genau das
tun wir
und sie tun das nicht sie tun das nicht
mit ihrer Forderung nach quentica und
online Durchsuchungen
ignorieren sie die hohen Anforderungen
die das Bundesverfassungsgericht daran
in der Vergangenheit zu Recht gestellt
hat immer mehr vom immer gleichen hat in
den letzten Jahren vor allem das
Bundesverfassungsgericht auf
trabgehalten mit solchen Rechts unsere
Vorschlägen die am Ende wieder in
karlsrelanten verlieren alle die
Freiheit die Bürgerinnen und Bürger und
am Ende auch die Sicherheit
sie fordern vor allem Dinge die
rechtsunsicher sind und ob sie
Sicherheit beitragen ist fraglich und
lehnen stattdessen Dinge ab die das
Vertrauen in die Polizei Stärken zum
Beispiel die polizeibeauftragten oder
die Pseudonyme Kennzeichnungspflicht und
da will ich Ihnen noch mal was sagen zum
Thema Verhältnis zwischen Staat und
Gesellschaft denn darum geht es auch bei
der Pseudonym Kennzeichnungspflicht es
ist so die Polizei übt das gewerkmonopol
des Staates aus und kann mit ihren
Maßnahmen in die Grundrechte aller
Menschen eingreifen es ist deshalb
unerlässlich in jedem Fall ein
transparentes und rechtsstaatliches
Handeln sicherzustellen und das das
trägt die dazu trägt die Einführung
einer Kennzeichnungspflicht bei das hat
auch das Bundesverwaltungsgericht schon
2019 bestätigt die Pseudonyme
Kennzeichnungspflicht dient demnach zum
einen der Stärkung der Transparenz und
der Bürger Nähe der Polizei zum anderen
gewährleistet sie die leichtere die
Arbeit bei Fehlverhalten damit beruhigt
sich die berüchtigt damit berücksichtigt
Sie außerdem die Rechtsprechung des
Europäischen Gerichtshofs für
Menschenrechte mit ihrer Ablehnung dazu
sind sie nicht mehr auf der Höhe der
Zeit sie ist mittlerweile Standard in
der Mehrheit der Bundesländer außer in
Bayern und dem Saarland ist sie überall
beschlossen oder auf den Weg gebracht in
vielen unionsrücken mit regierten
Ländern deswegen ist das im Endeffekt
auch im Sinne einer konsistenten
bundesweiten polizeipolitik sie sehen
sie sehen wir verfolgen einen klaren
Kompass wir haben die Sicherheit der
Menschen und den demokratischen
Rechtsstaat fest im Blick und wir
schaffen einen Rechtsrahmen wir schaffen
Rahmenbedingungen für eine
handlungsfähige und transparente Polizei
das bringen wir auch mit dem
bundespolizeigesetz auf den Weg das
werden sie noch sehen vielen Dank für
Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Marcel Emmerich für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen da ist ja ob man im
Innenausschuss und der nächste Redner
wird sein andre Hahn aus der
Linksfraktion ob man eben
parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
es war ja irgendwie schon zu erwarten
dass CDU und CSU passend zur
Weihnachtszeit noch ein paar Wünsche für
den law and order Geschenkekorb
präsentieren würden mit dem vorliegenden
Antrag hat die Union auch tatsächlich
geliefert
Akt der darin enthaltenen Forderungen
aus Sicht der Linken allerdings nicht
fangen wir mal mit dem unabhängigen
polizeibeauftragten an den sie immer
wieder leidenschaftlich ablehnen wovor
haben Sie eigentlich Angst liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
eigentlich müssten doch alle Demokraten
einen Interesse daran haben dass die
übergroße Mehrheit der Polizisten die
verantwortungsbewusst ihren Dienst
versehen dadurch geschützt werden das
schwarze Schafe mit übergriffigem oder
rechtswidrigen Verhalten möglichst
schnell aus dem Dienst entfernt werden
können
in dieser Woche in dieser Woche
antwortete das Innenministerium auf
unsere Anfrage zu den Zahlen über
Beschwerden die entlang von racial
Profiling Vorwürfen eingegangen sind vom
Januar 2021 bis Ende November 2022
wurden danach 100 Beschwerden
eingereicht darunter ist allerdings
nicht eine einzige Beschwerde die nach
Prüfung als begründet eingestuft wurden
wäre acht Fälle seien nicht aufklärbar
drei noch in Bearbeitung nun will ich
den Einsatzkräften und der Bundespolizei
keine Falschmeldung oder
beschwerdeunterdrückung unterstellen
aber schon rein statistisch gesehen ist
es höchst unwahrscheinlich dass nicht
eine einzige begründete Beschwerde in
einem Zeitraum von zwei Jahren dabei
gewesen sein soll mir sagt das wir
brauchen mehr denn je ein unabhängigen
polizeibeauftragten
Kollege Thron von der Union beklagt in
der aktuellen Ausgabe des lobby-magazins
moderne Polizei das angeblich zu große
Misstrauen gegenüber Polizisten wir
müssen uns gerade jetzt in der
Weihnachtszeit auch gar nicht streiten
wie die vorliegenden Zahlen auszulegen
sind wer Recht hat mit seiner
Wahrnehmung und wer falsch liegt zwei
Dinge allerdings geben mir schon zu
denken erstens zahlreiche
zivilgesellschaftliche Initiativen
nehmen ein Problem war dass ich dann
aber nicht mal ansatzweise in den
Aufklärungsraten widerspiegelt und dass
ich nur wenige von Rachel Profiling
betroffene Menschen überhaupt dadurch
durchringen eine offizielle Beschwerde
einzureichen ist angesichts dieser
Zahlen nicht verwunderlich
ich könnte Ihnen jetzt hier einige
persönliche Erfahrungen berichten die
ich in den letzten Jahren im Zug von der
tschechischen Grenze bei Bad Schandau
auf dem Weg nach Berlin erlebt habe
dafür fehlt mir leider die Zeit die
Fakten machen aber deutlich lieber
Kollege throm dass sie doch eigentlich
genau jetzt einen unabhängigen
polizeibeauftragten begrüßen müssen und
wenn sie dann recht behalten würden und
nahezu alle Beschwerden sich als
unbegründet erweisen würden dann
schaffen wir den beauftragten eben
wieder ab aber für Ihre komplette
Verweigerungshaltung habe ich keinerlei
Verständnis
meine Damen und Herren auch sonst ist
der Antrag voll von Geschenken an die
Bundespolizei die die Union verteilen
will Gummigeschosse und Tesa sollen
eingeführt werden ohne das überhaupt
belegbar ist dass dadurch der Einsatz
von Schusswaffen wirklich vermieden
werden kann und natürlich ist die Union
auch weiterhin gegen eine anonymisierte
Kennzeichnungspflicht für Polizistinnen
und Polizisten haben Sie sich eigentlich
mal im Rest von Europa oder in den USA
umgeschaut da ist diese Kennzeichnung
längst etabliert und das ist auch gut so
geben sie endlich ihren Widerstand
dagegen auf
meine Damen und Herren als vom Bundestag
gewähltes Mitglied des Gremiums dass die
Eingriffe in die Unverletzlichkeit der
Wohnung nach Artikel 13 Grundgesetz
überprüfen sollen muss ich einer
entsprechenden Befugnis für die
Bundespolizei eine klare Absage erteilen
für die Abwehr einer dringenden Gefahr
für Leib und Leben ist der Lauschangriff
auf den privaten Wohnraum ebenso
ungeeignet wie der Einsatz von
staatstrojanern die in die Union jetzt
für die Bundespolizei fordert wir als
LINKE lehnen das ab und abschließend
sage ich in Richtung Koalition legen sie
endlich einen eigenen Gesetzentwurf für
ein neues bundespolizeigesetz vor dann
könnten sie sich erstmals innenpolitisch
als sogenannte fortschrittskoalition
beweisen vielen Dank und frohe
Weihnachten
André Hahn für die Linksfraktion in der
Debatte zur Stärkung der Bundespolizei
der ein Antrag der Unionsfraktion
zugrunde liegt Manuel Höferlin aus der
FDP-Fraktion ist ja nächste Redner er
ist in politischer Sprecher
sehr verehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren
vor kurzem war ich zu Hause in Mainz
wieder mal bei der Bundespolizei im
Hauptbahnhof und dort müssen rund 70
bundespolizistinnen und Bundespolizisten
ihren Dienst tun es gibt wenig Platz für
die wichtige Arbeit zu wenig Platz für
Akten für Geräte die Umkleiden dort sind
inzwischen ausgelagerten ganzes Stück
vom Gebäude hinweg und auf einen Neubau
auf einen neue größere Unterkunft warten
die Kolleginnen und Kollegen dort schon
seit Jahren der Hauptbahnhof in Mainz
ist nur eines von Beispielen die viele
Polizei Dienststellen gerade an den
Böden sind ganz ähnlich aufgestellt
dabei verdanken wir die Sicherheit an
den Bahnhöfen an den Flughäfen genau
diesen Beamten die trotz dieser Umstände
ein hohes Maß an Motivation und
Leistungsbereitschaft zeigen und das
jeden Tag und dafür möchte ich einmal
herzlichen Dank sagen
eine moderne gut ausgestattete Polizei
ist deshalb für mich eines der
wichtigsten Themen und ein zentrales
Vorhaben dieser Koalition in der
Innenpolitik und daran arbeiten wir
intensiv um die Arbeit unserer
bundespolizistinnen und Bundespolizisten
besser effizienter zu gestalten denn vor
allen Dingen damit machen wir
Deutschland sicherer meine Damen und
Herren der Antrag der Union zeigt jedoch
dass sie diese Aufgabe nicht gewachsen
sind und auch in den letzten 16 Jahren
nicht gewachsen waren denn ihr Antrag
ist nichts anderes als eine Liste dessen
was sie 16 Jahre in der Innenpolitik
selbst nicht geschafft haben es ist eine
Dokumentation ihrer Versäumnisse und das
Bunde Polizei gesetzt ist ein gutes
Beispiel denn nicht einmal das haben sie
durchgekriegt in der letzten Legislatur
und deshalb ist es gut dass ich die
fortschrittskoalition jetzt in die
Bundespolizei gehört meine Damen und
Herren
es geht ihnen in Wirklichkeit auch gar
nicht um die Beamten das zeigt ihr
Antrag auch deutlich sondern es geht
ihnen einmal mehr um mehr Überwachung
der Telekommunikation um die Online
Durchsuchung die Wohnraumüberwachung die
automatische Gesichtserkennung und so
weiter ihre fragwürdigen Projekte mit
denen sie die Bürger immer wieder
drangsalieren wollen die sind krachend
gescheitert vor dem verfassungsgerichten
weil sie einfach nicht Verfassungsrecht
waren zuletzt mit der
Vorratsdatenspeicherung und sie
begreifen eines nicht mehr Überwachung
bedeutet nicht automatisch mehr
Sicherheit meine Damen und Herren
unsere Polizistinnen und Polizisten
brauchen andere Dinge viel dringender
sie brauchen bessere Ausrüstung auch
bessere Unterkünfte die Sie auf diese
seit Jahren warten sie brauchen klare
Zuständigkeitsregelungen und sie
brauchen eine verlässliche Politik und
im Gegensatz zu ihnen werden wir das
liefern sie machen ja auch ein paar ganz
gute Vorschläge in ihrem Antrag
zum Beispiel den Einsatz von Distanz
elektroimpulsgeräten sogenannten Tasern
oder bodycams leider viel zu spät weil
teilweise diese Projekte als
Pilotprojekte laufen immer noch nicht
ausgerollt sind dagegen wollen Sie jetzt
noch mehr sie wollen Gummi Geschosse bei
der Bundespolizei wollen sie ausrichten
da haben sie noch nicht mal geschafft in
den vielen Jahren die Taser ordentlich
auszurollen sie wollen sozusagen wieder
mit der Kanone auf Spatzen schießen sie
fordern jetzt eine
Sicherheitsüberprüfung bei
Neueinstellungen ein guter Vorschlag den
die FDP-Fraktion in der letzten
Wahlperiode bereits gefordert hat und
sie haben es versäumt das einzuführen
und wir gehen das jetzt mit dem neuen
Bundespolizei Gesetz an
die Arbeit der Polizei wird auch
verbessert im täglichen indem wir das
erfolgreiche Pilotprojekt P20
weiterentwickeln die Polizei in
Deutschland die Länderpolizeien die
Bundespolizei des BKA das Zeug
Kriminalamt und die Polizei des
Bundestages werden damit überall
jederzeit Zugriff auf die wichtigen
Informationen haben die sie täglich in
ihrem polizei-geschäft brauchen das
verbessert die Einsatzmöglichkeiten die
Effizienz der Polizei besser und das
verbessert die Arbeitsumstände der
Beamtinnen vor Ort meine Damen und
Herren wir sorgen für mehr
Digitalisierung die auch ein echten
Nutzen hat wir setzen uns für eine
flächendeckende Ausstattung für mobile
Endgeräte ein benutzerfreundlich direkt
Zugriff auf die relevanten Daten damit
stärken wir die Bundespolizei und sorgen
auch für moderne Sicherheitsbehörden
meine Damen und Herren
und weil ihr Antrag vor allen Dingen
eines aufzeigt nämlich was sie in den
letzten Jahren versäumt haben umzusetzen
was sie nicht geschafft haben
durchzusetzen ist es auch gut dass die
schwarzen Jahre im Innenministerium
vorbei sind die Sicherheitspolitik ist
jetzt
evidenzbasiert Grundrechts schonend und
wir schaffen verlässliche Instrumente
für die tägliche Arbeit der Polizisten
vor Ort das dürfen finde ich auch
diejenigen erwarten die im wahrsten
Sinne des Wortes jeden Tag ihren Kopf
für uns hinhalten und das werden wir
leisten vielen Dank
Manuel Höferlin war dass er in
politische Sprecher der FDP-Fraktion ihm
wird jetzt Folgen aus der Unionsfraktion
die ja diesen Antrag über den hier
diskutiert wird vorgelegt hat Petra
Nicolaisen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich würde die
Gelegenheit gerne dazu nutzen um darüber
zu sprechen wie die alltägliche Arbeit
der 54.000 bundespolizistinnen und
Bundespolizisten in unserem Lande
eigentlich aussieht die Bundespolizei
führt jährlich unzählige von
Amtshandlungen aus das wissen sie
Objektschutz Grenzkontrollen Verhandlung
Festnahmen und der Kampf auch gegen die
organisierte Kriminalität gehören zu
einigen der vielfältigen Aufgaben die
Tag für Tag gewissenhaft erfüllt werden
und das sind Aufgaben die unsere
Sicherheit unserer Sicherheit dienen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen unsere
Aufgabe ist es die Bundespolizei zu
stärken dazu müssen die
Herausforderungen endlich angegangen
werden und dabei bin ich sicher der
Bundesregierung sind diese
Herausforderung und Belastung
hinlänglich bekannt und doch passiert zu
wenig
die Zahl der Aufgaben wächst der
aufgabendruck ist enorm und die
Gefahrenlage hoch wir beobachten eine
neue Qualität der Aggression gegen die
Polizei geringere Hemmschwellen die
Festnahme bewaffneter Reichsbürger und
die Polizisten Morde zum Beispiel in
Kusel wir erleben
hochprofessionalisierte Strukturen im
Bereich der schleusungskriminalität und
neue Möglichkeiten neue mögliche
Gefahren durch Cyberangriffe Sabotage
und Drohnen darauf muss die
Bundespolizei vorbereitet werden weil
wir alle eine zuverlässige
funktionsfähige und gut ausgestattete
Bundespolizei erwarten und auch brauchen
mir ist es wichtig Revue passieren zu
lassen was bisher allein in diesem Jahr
an Aufgaben hinzukamen zu Beginn dieses
Jahres waren es die
Montagsdemonstrationen und rohaufläufe
corona-demos und die vielen
Schutzsuchenden aus der Ukraine im
Sommer dann flughafenchaos wer musste
helfen die Bundespolizei Einsatzlagen
bei Fußballspielen und der Reiseverkehr
der Fans die Bundespolizei ist auch hier
gefordert und so kamen 2021 22 mehr als
400.000 Einsatzstunden zusammen in
diesem Herbst klimaaktivisten am
Berliner Flughafen Einsätze für die
Bundespolizei und nun weiter zunehmenden
Migrationsbewegungen die Bundespolizei
sichert die Grenzen und genau deshalb
haben wir diesen Antrag gestellt und
eingebracht weil wir als
cdu/csu-fraktion den Ernst der Lage
erkennen und konkrete Vorschläge machen
wir fordern sie auf Liebe
Bundesregierung in unserem Antrag hier
und heute erstens sorgen sie für mehr
Personal bei angemessener Bezahlung
zweitens statten Sie die Einsatzkräfte
sicherer und moderner aus um neuen
Herausforderungen anzugehen und das
Personal gut zu schützen und dazu gehört
auch dass sie die Situation der
Dienststellen und der Unterbringung der
Bundespolizei Regeln und drittens
greifen Sie unsere Vorschläge zu
zeitgemäßen handlungsbefugnissen bitte
auf
die Bundespolizei braucht Möglichkeiten
um neue Gefahren zu begegnen und besser
ermitteln zu können und Kollege Emmerich
der
polizeibeauftragte trägt in der Tat
nicht zu mehr Bürgernähe bei
abschließend möchte ich auch die
künftige finanzielle Situation zu
sprechen kommen und ich kann es wirklich
beim besten Willen nicht nachvollziehen
warum die Bundesregierung ausgerechnet
jetzt bei der Bundespolizei sparen will
ihnen muss ich
[Applaus]
künftig ist und natürlich auch
realitätsfern
wir als unionsgeführte Bundesregierung
haben seit 2016 in diese Behörde mehr
investiert als in allen anderen
Bereichen der inneren Sicherheit und
lieber Kollege Uli Grötsch sie wissen es
besser als das was sie eben kundgetan
haben wir haben dort in großer Koalition
viel investiert und das Polizeigesetz
ist im Bundesrat gescheitert an einem
Ministerpräsidenten der SPD
was wir Mülltonne aufgebaut haben eine
höhere Personaldecke die Erhöhung der
Polizei Zulage und viele weitere
Verbesserungen das alles bauen Sie jetzt
hier sukzessive wieder ab und machen
diesen Erfolg der letzten sechs Jahre
zunichte das ist eher Wagnis als
Fortschritt was wir gerade passiert sie
sparen an Befugnissen und an Kosten und
das Zulassen unserer Sicherheit und der
Sicherheit der Einsatzkräfte das ist
absoluter Rückschritt ich muss doch
schwer hoffen dass sie sich zeitnah
besinnen herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
nächste Rednerin für die SPD-Fraktion
kamen Wege
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
demokratischen Fraktionen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren die Bundespolizei ist
aktuell sehr stark und vielfältig
gefordert in diesem Jahr sind es vor
allem die Auswirkungen des russischen
Angriffskrieges sei es der
schutzkritischer Infrastruktur auch zu
sehen oder die Unterstützung bei der
Ankunft von geflüchteten aus der Ukraine
hier möchte ich besonders erwähnen dass
die Bundespolizei dankenswerterweise
schnell reagiert hat als nach den ersten
Ankünften von ukrainischen Frauen und
Kindern Berichte über Menschenhandel und
sexualisierte Übergriffe die Runde
machten die Präsenz wurde verstärkt und
vor Ort wurde sensibilisiert genauso
muss es laufen
aber auch die Razzia gegen
reichsbürgerinnen in den vergangenen
Woche kann man nicht unerwähnt lassen
die Bundespolizei unterstützt immer
häufiger bei der Abwehr der großen
Bedrohung durch Rechtsextremismus auch
bei dieser bundesweiten Razzia war sie
mit hunderten Beamtinnen beteiligt
darunter auch viele Spezialkräfte wir
haben den Rechtsextremismus als die
aktuell größte Gefahr für die für unsere
Demokratie identifiziert und für den
Kampf gegen Rechts brauchen wir starke
Sicherheitsbehörden auf die
Bundespolizei können und müssen wir uns
an dieser Stelle verlassen zur Erfüllung
ihrer wichtigsten auf ihres wichtigsten
Auftrags benötigt die Bundespolizei
nicht wie Sie Ihren Antrag schreiben
drei sondern aus meiner Sicht sogar fünf
Dinge eine starke Bundespolizei braucht
ausreichend Personal gutes Material gute
Arbeitsbedingungen Anerkennung für die
Arbeit der Beamtinnen und schließlich
eine moderne gesetzliche
Arbeitsgrundlage all das schaffen wir
all das schafft unsere Innenministerin
Nancy fazer all das schafft die Ampel
und ich möchte Ihnen auch konkret
erläutern wie wir in diesen fünf
Bereichen aktiv werden oder bereits
jetzt aktiv geworden sind erstens mehr
Personal wir haben durch die
Haushaltsberatung 1000 neue Stellen bei
der Bundespolizei ermöglicht diese neuen
Beamtinnen werden unter anderem zum
Schutz von Flug und Sehhilfen und dem
Grenzschutz eingesetzt zweitens neues
Material wie ein bisschen ganz gezielt
in die Bedarfe der Bundespolizei wir
schaffen das an was durch die
verstärkten Herausforderungen gebraucht
wird die Bundespolizei sehe hat
beispielsweise ein Verfahrens
Trainingszentrum mit dem modernsten
schiffführungssimulator Europas eröffnet
ein absolutes Alleinstellungsmerkmal mit
Blick auf die aktuellen
Herausforderungen im Maritim Raum ist
dies eine dringende notwendige
Weiterentwicklung ein weiteres Beispiel
im Haushalt für 2023 haben wir 21
Millionen Euro zu Beschaffung neuer
kontroll- und Streifenboote bei der
Bundespolizei sowie mehrzweckbote für
die GSG9 vereinbart gute
Arbeitsbedingungen für in Deutschland
kommt es auf eine motivierte und gut
ausgebildete
Bundespolizei an genau deshalb stärken
wir Supervision sowie Fort- und
Weiterbildung nur so kann man eine
attraktive Arbeitgeberin auch bleiben
Wertschätzung für Polizistinnen in
dieser Legislaturperiode werden wir
endlich die Polizei Zulage wieder in
Ruhe gehaltsfähig gestalten können das
ist uns als SPD seit vielen Jahren ein
großes Anliegen und Liebe Union bei
ihnen habe ich das jetzt noch nicht so
häufig gehört mit der Wiedereinführung
werden die Leistungen der Beamten
endlich auch finanziell anerkannt eine
gute Nachricht für die Kolleginnen und
das bundespolizegesetz ja da stand in
großen Teilen noch aus dem Jahr 1994 und
deswegen werden wir selbstverständlich
einen Gesetzesentwurf vorlegen der
Versuch einer Stabilisierung der
Rechtsgrundlagen ist ja wie bereits
bekannt im Bundesrat gescheitert wir
schaffen nun ein neues und zeitgemäßes
Gesetz das für eine moderne und
bürgernahe Polizei stehen wird für
diesen für dieses Ziel ja bürgernah das
ist für sie vielleicht komisch Herr
Abenteuer für uns ist das
selbstverständlich für dieses Ziel
braucht es in unseren Augen
sie sind die Grundvoraussetzung für ein
verfassungsfestes Gesetz wir wegen genau
ab welcher heraus welche
handlungsbefugnisse für die
Bundespolizei notwendig sind und welche
eben nicht unser Credo ist dabei nicht
wie in ihrem Antrag mehr ist immer
besser diese Haltung würde ich als einen
konservativen Reflex bezeichnen den wir
als SPD endlich nicht mehr mittragen
müssen
stattdessen wollen wir die Bundespolizei
als Bürger nahe Polizei Stärken dafür
ist das Vertrauen in unsere
Sicherheitsbehörden ein zentraler
Schlüssel gedachte deswegen werden wir
die Kennzeichnungspflicht und einen
unabhängigen polizeibeauftragten
einführen beide Maßnahmen sind Ausdruck
einer modernen professionell und vor
allem recht staatlich arbeiten in
Polizei sie sind Ausdruck eines offenen
und transparenten Auftreten des Staates
gegenüber ihren BürgerInnen das
Vertrauen der Bürger in die Polizei wird
damit gestärkt mit Blick in die Zukunft
ist die Bundespolizei also gut
aufgestellt und besonders gut ist dass
wir jetzt die Innenministerin Stellen
vielen Dank
Carmen Wege aus der SPD-Fraktion in der
Debatte über die Bundespolizei
beziehungsweise deren Stärkung bzw den
Vorstellungen die die Unionsfraktion
dazu hat die hat den entsprechenden
Antrag hier vorgelegt nächste Rednerin
ist Irene miralitsch erste
parlamentarische Geschäftsführerin der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen und
ehemalige Polizeibeamtin
liebe Kollegen die Bundespolizei ist ein
Eckpfeiler und Garant für die innere
Sicherheit unseres Landes sie zu Stärken
auf hohem Niveau auszustatten und
einsatzbereit zu halten ist unser aller
Verpflichtung meine Damen und Herren
nicht zuletzt in diesen schwierigen
Zeiten von allgegenwärtigen Krisen und
dem Krieg in der Ukraine verdienen die
Beschäftigten der Bundespolizei unseren
besonderen Dank und Wertschätzung meine
Damen und Herren und deshalb hätte es
mich umso mehr gefreut wenn wir
inzwischen die Ruhe gehaltsfähigkeit der
Polizei Zulage wieder eingeführt hätten
genauso wie wir es auch um
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart haben
leider hängt der bereits fertige
Gesetzentwurf der Innenministerin noch
im Bundesfinanzministerium zur Freigabe
fest ich appelliere an dieser Stelle
aber auch ausdrücklich an unseren
Koalitionspartner es ist wichtig dass
wir in dieser wichtigen Frage
Vorankommen denn gerade für die
zahlreichen Beschäftigten der
Bundespolizei im mittleren Dienst wäre
es ein so wichtiges Signal in diesen
schwierigen Zeiten da dürfen wir Sie
nicht im Regen stehen lassen meine Damen
und Herren
und nun komme ich zu ihrem Antrag liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
sie haben ja durchaus ein paar
vernünftige Dinge aufgeschrieben aber
mit dem meisten was sie da vorschlagen
sind sie ja schon in der letzten
Wahlperiode krachend gescheitert und
nach diesem völlig verkorksten
Gesetzgebungsverfahren ist es gut dass
die Ampel jetzt anpackt was sie damals
verbockt haben nach fast 30 Jahren
Stillstand werden wir das
bundespolizeigesetz endlich novellieren
damit treffen wir eine
Richtungsentscheidung für die Zukunft
der Bundespolizei wir werden darauf
achten dass die Bundespolizei moderne
und vor allen Dingen rechts sicher
ausgestaltete Rechtsgrundlagen erhält so
wie es für ihre wichtige Arbeit
erforderlich ist
und dazu gehört auch die Debatte darüber
zu führen dass die Bundespolizei die
Zuständigkeit für die Bearbeitung von
Verbrechens Tatbeständen bekommt sie
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union
und das haben sie sich jetzt hier auch
schon öfter anhören müssen fordern
hingegen die Nutzung automatischer
Gesichtserkennung sie wollen die Quellen
TKÜ für die Bundespolizei und die
Wohnraumüberwachung damit laufen sie
nicht nur meilenweit am tatsächlichen
Bedarf vorbei sondern sie würden auch
noch einen ganzen Berg voller
verfassungsrechtlicher Unsicherheiten
schaffen was wir aber brauchen ist gut
ausgebildetes gut ausgestattetes
Personal das kriminalistisch arbeitet
und keine Rechtsunsicherheiten meine
Damen und Herren
ein sehr wichtiges Thema ist zudem eine
professionelle und vor allem
diskriminierungsfreie Arbeit der
Bundespolizei und seit Jahren wird
Deutschland auch unter der
unionsgeführten Bundesregierung von
europäischen Institutionen dazu
aufgefordert wirksam gegen das
sogenannte racial Profiling vorzugehen
und die Novelle des bundespolizegesetzes
bietet nun eine echte Chance dafür eben
mehr Rechtssicherheit für
Personenkontrollen zu schaffen und eben
gleichzeitig Diskriminierungen
vorzubeugen und hier möchten wir
zusammen mit unseren Koalitionspartnern
an der Entwicklung von alltagstauglichen
und praktikablen Lösungen arbeiten wie
zum Beispiel die flächendeckende
Ausstattung der Beamten und Beamten mit
bodycams die auch verlange noch
eingeschaltet werden oder die
Ausstellung von kontrollquittungen sind
wichtige Maßnahmen für die wir uns
einsetzen wollen und nein liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union um
uns allen hier ihre plattitüten zu
ersparen diese Maßnahmen drücken nicht
mangelndes Vertrauen in die Arbeit der
Polizei aus im Gegenteil weil wir
schaffen Vertrauen meine Damen und
Herren
denn die
allermeisten Polizisten machen eine
hervorrationelle
Arbeit und wir wollen Sie darin
unterstützen und ihnen die
Rechtsgrundlagen an die Hand geben die
sie für ein professionelles einschreiten
auch so dringend brauchen und wer immer
nur nichts tut ja und sagt die Polizei
macht immer alles richtig der zerstört
in Wahrheit das Vertrauen in diese so
wichtige Institution unserer
Gesellschaft und das muss sich dringend
ändern
deshalb ist es auch so wichtig dass wir
demnächst auch ein Gesetzentwurf zu
Schaffung eines unabhängigen
polizeibeauftragten vorlegen werden wir
wollen dadurch eine unabhängige
Ansprechperson für Polizistinnen und
Polizisten und für Bürgerinnen und
Bürger hier beim Deutschen Bundestag
schaffen aber auch dagegen polemisieren
sie ja immer gerne ja das Schreiben sie
ja auch in ihrem Antrag aber ihr
Konservativismus ist eben nach dem Motto
gestrickt einfach immer dasselbe sagen
egal wie die Welt sich verändert wir als
Ampel werden aber dafür sorgen dass sich
etwas ändert und zwar zum Positiven denn
es geht um eine Kultur des Vertrauens
und der Wertschätzung der wir uns
verpflichtet fühlen Vertrauen in die
Polizei Beamten und Beamten des Bundes
die wir mit neuen modernen Kompetenzen
ausstatten wollen Vertrauen der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in die
Sicherheitsbehörden unseres
demokratischen Rechtsstaats und
Wertschätzung die mehr ist als eine
hohle Phrase unsere Polizistinnen und
Polizisten brauchen kein Mitleid oder
Schulterklopfen sie verdienen
aufrichtige Anerkennung ihrer Arbeit die
sich in vielen Maßnahmen ausdrückt und
in diesem Sinne wünsche ich uns allen
eine gute und besinnliche Weihnachtszeit
denn in der Ruhe liegt die Kraft die wir
auch für die anstrengenden und die
anstehenden sicherheitspolitischen
reformendebatten zu dringend brauchen
ganz herzlichen
Irene Mia Alice die erste
parlamentarische Geschäftsführerin der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen hat hier
gesprochen zum Antrag der Unionsfraktion
zur Stärkung der Bundespolizei das
bleibt auch noch ein bisschen Thema auch
bei Stefan Thome der einer der
Parlamentarischen Geschäftsführer der
FDP-Fraktion ist
wenn man sich den Antrag der Union so
durchliest dann fühlt man sich
jedenfalls an ein paar Stellen als wäre
man in eine Kammer des Schreckens
grenzenlose überwachungs-
alle nur irgendwie denkbaren Befugnisse
hineinpacken würden und weitergeben
würden wenn man sie nur lassen würde
dabei sind ihre Fantasie irgendwie keine
Grenzen gesetzt von der Befugnis zum
Einsatz moderner Technik bis hin zur
Nutzung von Gesichtserkennung an
Bahnhöfen Flughäfen und hin zur Wohnraum
Überwachung und schließlich fast schon
erwartungsgemäß wie auch in Stichwort im
Theater die Befugnis zur
telegationsüberwachung sowie zu Befugnis
der sogenannten und der Online
Durchsuchung da fehlt nichts aus dem
Szenario aber
es ist eine Tat jetzt vieles dabei was
man sich in Bezug auf die Ausweitung von
bundespolizeilichen Befugnissen gerade
nicht wünschen würden denn der Feier den
fassungsstaat Macht von Eingriffe und
überwachungsbefugnissen wirklich nur
sehr sehr zurückhaltend und maßvollen
gebraucht
zudem verkennen sie in ihrem Antrag den
Stellenwert die Möglichkeiten die
Chancen die Optionen eines unabhängigen
polizeibeauftragten den sie als
überflüssig ach in ihrem Antrag und so
macht ihr Antrag eines deutlich es ist
gut dass die FDP in der
Regierungsverantwortung mit ist mit den
Grünen und SPD denn mit uns ist eine
solchen rücksichtslosen und übrigens
auch weitgehend unnötigen
Generalangriff auf die Bürgerrechte und
auch auf unsere IT-Sicherheit wie sie
hier Vorhaben gerade nicht geben mit
diesem Antrag wird die Union einer
vernünftigen Reform des
bundespolizeigesetzes nicht einmal im
Ansatz Gericht
ist auch wirklich interessant wie
selbstbewusst die Union hier die
Stärkung der Bundespolizei fordert denn
die wesentlichen Elemente des
bundespolizeigesetzes stammt aus dem
Jahr 1994 94 damals ist darüber noch
Bundesgrenzschutz und eigentlich wollte
auch die letzte große Koalition das
Gesetz modernisieren ist aber damit dann
im Jahr 2021 gescheitert nur zwei Monate
vor der Bundestagswahl das heißt wenn
Sie jetzt das Thema zum zu ihrem Thema
machen dann zeigen Sie woran sie jetzt
zuletzt eben noch stecken geblieben sind
werden Sie also am Ende doch die
Bundespolizei in ihrer veralteten das
ist Grundlage zurückgelassen haben
werden wir die Modernisierung des
Bundespräsident anpacken denn die
Koalition hat die Überarbeitung des
Bundespolizei Gesetzes zu einem der
wichtigen Vorhaben gemacht die wollen
für eine gute Personal und
Sachausstattung sorgen und vor allem
auch den Zustand der Liegenschaften
verbessern und den Abbau von Überstunden
angehen vor allem der Zustand vieler
vieler Liegenschaften die Bundespolizei
gerade in Bahnhöfen nutzt ist wirklich
für die Polizeibeamtinnen und Beamten
untragbar wir müssen dafür sorgen dass
die notwendige Ausstattung und
angemessene Unterbringung gewährleistet
wird und ein letzten Punkt will ich noch
tun für ein wichtigen Punkt die
Kompetenzen der Bundespolizei in Bezug
auf Rückführungen dazu Stärken wo
Bundespolizei Beamte in ihrem
Zuständigkeitsbereich vor allem an
Bahnhöfen den unrechtmäßigen Aufenthalt
eine Person feststellen und dann sollte
sie auch für Rückführung zuständig sein
das sind
Zuständigkeitsfragen zwischen Bund und
Ländern zu klären aber es ist jedenfalls
sinnvoll und auch notwendig dass da wo
Ausweispflicht denn angegriffen werden
auch die Bundespolizei wo sie sie andere
für Rückführung sorgen kann das ist noch
ein Punkt den wir angehen wollen
ansonsten werden wir dieses Thema im
nächsten Jahr beherzt angehen vielen
Dank und in allen vor Weihnachten guten
Start ins neue Jahr
Stefan Thome aus der FDP-Fraktion einer
von ja fast allen die hier schöne
Weihnachten wünschen am Ende ihrer Rede
es ist ja der letzte Sitzungstag in
diesem Jahr mutmaßlich jedenfalls Silke
launert jetzt für die Unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren
alles reden ist sinnlos wenn das
Vertrauen fehlt Worte des Philosophen
Kafka die zum Ausdruck bringen worauf es
am Ende wirklich ankommt nicht
ausschweifende reden betreuerungen
Versprechungen sondern schlichtweg auf
eins Vertrauen und nur derjenige welche
das Gefühl hat dass ihm vertraut wird
der fühlt sich auch wertgeschätzt und
vom Vertrauen der Bundesregierung unsere
Polizei in all die Männer und Frauen die
unsere Sicherheit garantieren Tag und
Nacht 24 Stunden am Tag 365 Tage im Jahr
da muss ich sagen spüre ich eher weniger
in diesem Koalitionsvertrag noch so toll
hieß schöne Worte die Wertschätzung für
unsere Polizistinnen und Polizisten
drücken sich aus auch durch eine gute
Personal und Sachausstattung den Zustand
der Liegenschaften den Abbau von
Überstunden und wieder Einführung der
Polizei Zulage aus wie sie die Realität
aus wir kennen dass sie die
Vollzugsbeamten stärken wollen und dann
nicht gekürzt haben pauschal mit diesen
1,5 Prozent dafür haben wir uns auch
ausgesprochen dass erkennen wir an alle
Dings trifft natürlich die Einkommen 5%
in der Verwaltung und da hören wir
Stimmen die sagen das macht uns den
Laden kaputt weil wir gerade natürlich
in den letzten Jahren viel ausgebaut
haben und diese Einsparung wäre
drastisch wir haben Sachen
mitgekürzungen wir haben die geplante
Kennzeichnungspflicht also von
Bürgernähe das ist ja abstrus aber das
war ja jemand anders der diesen
Begriffen den Zusammenhang gebraucht hat
wir haben die Pläne zu Ernennung eines
Polizeibeamten ja interessant was
Wertschätzung ist und es ist eben nicht
so wie Frau mihalle Glitch sagt dass das
nichts mit Vertrauen zu tun hat ich kann
Ihnen sagen ich unterhalte mich auch ich
war letzte Woche erst bei meiner
Bundespolizei nicht auch die Soldaten
auf die Polizisten die Reden in der
vorhergehenden Debatte haben es gezeigt
fast alle Beiträge aus links grün haben
die Polizisten angegriffen wie wichtig
ist sie dadurch genau zu kontrollieren
und die vielen schwarzen Schafe zu
filtern das ist genau das Gegenteil von
Wertschätzung
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen gibt es
nicht zu Nulltarif des kostet
54.000 Männer und Frauen und deshalb so
bitter es ist eine schwarze Schaf zu
haben das ist nicht entschuldbar so sehr
müssen wir die anderen 54.000 Männer und
Frauen der Bundespolizei sehen die jeden
Tag ihren Kopf hinhalten bereit sind in
Gefahrensituation ja vielleicht sogar
ihr Leben zu lassen und für diese Person
trägt die Bundesregierung die
Verantwortung und diese Person haben
unser Vertrauen unser Wertschätzung
verdient wir brauchen sie
die Rückendeckung die diese brauchen
haben wir in der letzten Periode gezeigt
auch hier wieder Frau mihalic 16 Jahre
nichts gemacht haben sie letzte Periode
geschlafen kurz Zusammenfassung 8.300
neue Stellen Erhöhung umfasst ein
fünftelungserhöhung 10% Polizei Zulage
Einstiegsgehalt angehoben also wer hier
sich hinstellt und sagt hohle Phrasen 16
ja nichts gemacht der hat wirklich
offensichtlich nicht aufgepasst
das Signal ist klar dass wir ausgesendet
haben wir sehen welche wichtige Aufgabe
er für uns alle erledigt wie vielen Dank
dass Sie das mal angesprochen haben sie
waren der einzige die 450
Bundespolizisten die in dem Einsatz
lässt der Woche aktiv dabei waren und
nehme ich den Job gemacht haben und
unsere Demokratie verteidigt haben wir
sehen was ihr leistet wir stehen an
eurer Seite wir unterstützen euch und
vor allem wir vertrauen euch und das ist
eben genau das Gegenteil was die Ampel
macht wir hören immer nur was alles
falsch läuft wie man kontrollieren muss
wie immer alle möglichen Leute
rausbringen muss schaffen sie nötigen
Rahmenbedingungen machen sie den Weg
frei für die Erweiterung der
Zuständigkeit der Bundespolizei machen
sie den Weg frei für die Befugnisse zu
Telekommunikationsüberwachung
online Durchsuchung
schenken Sie unseren Leuten bei der
Bundespolizei vertrauen
sie haben es verdient
nächste Rednerin für die SPD-Fraktion
Simona Kos
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren die Polizei
weiter Bundespolizei weiter stärken so
der Titel des Antrags der Union und wer
mag dem widersprechen
was die Ampelkoalition für die Stärkung
der Bundespolizei tut und im Haushalt
223 verankert ist haben wir schon von
einigen Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Koalition gehört ich möchte es trotzdem
noch mal wiederholen 1.000 neue Stellen
acht neue Stellen für dringend
gebrauchte sozialarbeitende um
Psychologinnen und Psychologen für die
aus- und Fortbildungszentren der
Bundespolizei
21,1 Millionen Euro für die Beschaffung
neuer Kontrolle und Streifenboote und
neuer mehrzweckbote der GSG 9
3,9 Millionen Euro für die Beschaffung
von Drohnen zum Schutz kritischer
Infrastruktur
die Ausstattung der Bundespolizei im
Haushalt 223 ist dank Ampelkoalition und
bundesinnenministerin Nancy Feser in
guten Händen
wir nehmen den Titel ihres Antrages
Ernst wir stärken die Bundespolizei in
diesem Jahr habe ich insgesamt drei Mal
den Standort Blumenberg der
Bundespolizei besucht zuletzt gemeinsam
am 11 November mit meinen Kollegen Uli
Grötsch die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
dort sind zuständig für den Grenzschutz
Migrationsarbeit an den Grenzen zu Polen
Österreich Tschechien und der Schweiz
und wir wissen meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren wie die Situation an
den Grenzen ist sie sind zuständig für
die Sicherung von Bahnhöfen und
Gleisanlagen für Einsätze zur
Unterstützung bei Versammlung in den
Bundesländern Berlin Brandenburg und
Sachsen sowie für Einsätze zur
Unterstützung des BKA unter anderem beim
G7 Gipfel
bei unserem Besuch waren wir tief davon
beeindruckt mit welchem großen
Engagement die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Bundespolizei unter schwierigen
Bedingungen ihre Arbeit leisten
falls es Sie interessiert werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
dann machen Sie sich doch einmal die
Mühe und schauen sich an und da welchem
Bedingungen die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Bundespolizei dort arbeiten müssen
sie werden Häuser in der Bausubstanz aus
den 80er Jahren vorfinden die den
Anforderungen die wir und sie an die
Bundespolizei Stellen nicht mehr gerecht
werden
werte Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
Union bevor sie jetzt mit dem Finger auf
die Ampel zeigen diese Rahmenbedingungen
herrschen dort in Blumberg seit Jahren
dringend wirklich dringend müssen jetzt
folgende Bauvorhaben umgesetzt werden
der Bau einer Befehlsstelle die
Bereitstellung eines führungsraums die
Erweiterung von Trainingsmöglichkeiten
neue Unterkünfte für die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und eine neue Mensa es gibt
einen Masterplan über 15 Jahre mit fünf
Bauabschnitten wichtig ist dass endlich
mit der konkreten Umsetzung begonnen
wird wir werden das jetzt in Angriff
nehmen was der Innenminister Seehofer
mit seinem bayerischen Blick
möglicherweise nicht hat sehen können
oder sehen wollen
wir werden und ich persönlich werde mich
dafür einsetzen den Standort so zu
ertüchtigen dass er einer modernen
Bundespolizei entspricht
ich danke allen Kolleginnen und Kollegen
in Zivil und den Uniform für ihre
Engagement und ihren Einsatz denn sie
leisten unter schwierigen Bedingungen
eine erstklassige Arbeit
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
wir schauen nach vorne wir packen an ich
danke Ihnen für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit und
wünsche Ihnen ein schönes Weihnachtsfest
und einen guten Rutsch
Simona Corus aus der
spd-fraktion-rednerin gewesen in dieser
Debatte jetzt kommt philipp am Tor aus
der Unionsfraktion er ist uns Sprecher
der Unionsfraktion für
Staatsorganisation und
Staatsmodernisierung
müssen wir jetzt in der zurückliegenden
Stunde geführt haben über die
Bundespolizei die hat schon sehr sehr
deutlich gezeigt und ich hoffe dass das
viele Bundespolizisten in unserem Land
auch zur Kenntnis nehmen wo die
einzelnen Fraktionen dieses Parlaments
ihre Schwerpunkte setzen die einen wir
haben in den vergangenen Jahren dafür
gesorgt dass es ein beispiellosen
aufwuchs bei der Bundespolizei gab sie
haben stattdessen den
gesamtpersonalansatz der Bundespolizei
reduziert und man hat den Eindruck die
wichtigste zukunftsstelle für die
Bundespolizei in der Zukunft sind bei
ihnen nicht neue Einsatzhundertschaften
hier dringend bräuchte sondern ein
polizeibeauftragter liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen wir haben uns in den
vergangenen Jahren und tun es auch mit
dieser Debatte sehr klar dafür
eingesetzt dass die Bundespolizei
Instrumente und Befugnisse auf der Höhe
der Zeit bekommt statt neuer Befugnisse
und Instrumente gibt es von ihnen eine
Kennzeichnungspflicht für Polizisten und
Polizisten das ist zu wenig liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und man hat den
Eindruck in ihrem Vorträgen ist das
Hauptthema eine sogenannte bürgernahe
Bundespolizei das scheint ihr Wunsch zu
sein ich sage Ihnen das ist auch die
Realität in unserem Land eine Realität
die sie verkennen und das wichtigste
Ziel was es braucht ist eine
Bundespolizei die wirksam gegen
Straftäter und Extremisten vorgehen kann
und dafür braucht es unseren Antrag
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
nach einer wirklich beispiellosen
Erfolgsgeschichte personellen Stärkung
die wir ja nicht nur alleine sondern
auch mit der SPD die sich zum Teil daran
ja nicht mehr erinnern kann und glaubt
in den letzten 16 Jahren sah alles
schlecht gewesen in dieser gemeinsamen
Erfolgsgeschichte haben wir dafür
gesorgt dass 54
000 Bundespolizisten unsere innere
Sicherheit stärken unsere Freiheit
verteidigen und diese Menschen brauchen
einen rechtlichen Instrumentenkasten auf
der Höhe der Zeit wir haben es gehört
das Bundespolizei Gesetz es ist 30 Jahre
alt es braucht ein Neuanlauf und ich
sage gerade irgendwo Sie uns immer
vorwerfen wir würden hier nur meckern
wir würden nur kritisieren wir haben
konkrete Vorschläge gemacht sie kündigen
nur an wo ist denn ihr Gesetzentwurf zum
Bundespolizei gesetzt liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen und
ich fände übrigens toll die
spatzenpfeifen das ja von den Dächern es
gibt ja den Referenten Entwurf wir haben
gehört der steckt jetzt im
Finanzministerium fest ist übrigens auch
ein tolles Zeichen vom Parlamentarismus
dass wir die Dinge irgendwo in der
Öffentlichkeit diskutiert finden aber
nicht hier im Parlament trotzdem wissen
wir natürlich was sie vorschlagen es ist
ungenügend Einführung von Tasern den
sogenannten Distanz elektroimpulsgeräten
Fehlanzeige quellt
telekommunikations-überwachung
Fehlanzeige online Durchsuchung
Fehlanzeige stattdessen
Kennzeichnungspflicht und
polizeibeauftragte liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ihr Entwurf trägt den Namen
Bundespolizei gesetzt ist in der Sache
aber keine notwendige Stärkung der
Bundespolizei liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen den
gibt es stattdessen von uns und ich will
Ihnen auch noch mal sagen sie fallen
insbesondere die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der SPD deutlich hinter dem
zurück was wir in der vergangenen
Wahlperiode auch gemeinsam beschlossen
haben das bundespolizeigesetz das im
Bundesrat gescheitert ist dass wir nicht
irgendwie meine unverbindliche
Willenserklärung der Union sondern es
war ein Beschluss dieses Parlaments und
es ist gescheitert auch maßgeblich an
der SPD an Boris Pistorius und am
Bundesrat liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das dürfen wir auch nicht vergessen und
Frau Feser ich sage ihm sie müssen dann
auch liefern und sollten dann im
Bundesrat auch dafür sorgen sich etwas
zuzutauen und jetzt nicht lieblos das
Bundespolizei Gesetz so auszugestalten
dass all die Dinge die eine
Zustimmungspflicht im Bundesrat auslösen
dass die alle gestrichen werden weil sie
es sich nicht zutrauen dort die
Ministerpräsidenten zu überzeugen und
ich finde wer andere Ministerpräsidenten
nicht überzeugen kann ein gutes die
Polizei Gesetz zu machen der sollte auch
selbst nicht das Amt der
Ministerpräsidentin anstreben das ist
bei Boris rein deutlich besser
aufgehoben frohe Weihnachten liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Weihnachtswünsche auch vom fachsprecher
für staatsorganisationen Philipp Amthor
aus der Unionsfraktion er war der
vorletzte Redner in dieser Debatte in
der es um die Bundespolizei geht und um
deren Stärkung da gibt es natürlich
unterschiedliche Vorstellungen auf der
einen wie auf der anderen Seite jetzt
noch mal Sebastian Fiedler für die
SPD-Fraktion
können was jetzt gerade aufgehört werden
muss lieber Kollege am Tor und die
Kollegen der Union ich empfinde das
offen gestanden auch als persönliche
Beleidigung ich habe mich jahrelang für
die Belange der Polizeibeamten
Ehrenamtliche und hauptamtlich
eingesetzt und glauben Sie eigentlich
die SPD und die Ampelkoalition werden
mit Klammerbeutel gepudert ich bin kein
Ausnahme sondern ich rede hier für die
ampelfraktion für die Fortschritt und
natürlich stehen wir hinter unseren
Sicherheitsbehörden und nur weil sie
jetzt zu schaufensterantrag kurz vor
Weihnachten noch mal irgendwie
reinhängen und meinen jetzt noch mal das
gesamte Reportage oder Politik reinigen
zu müssen ist das sozusagen kein
Gegenpol sondern sie tun so als stünde
die Bundespolizei mit all ihren
vielfältigen Aufgaben viele sind schon
genannt worden Sicherung der Grenzen
Flughäfen Spezialeinheiten Hubschrauber
Wasserfahrzeuge paar tausend Leute die
kripoarbeit dort machen Auslandseinsätze
Botschaften werden überwacht oder tun
sie im Pension so als stünde das alles
im luftleeren Raum und ich finde das
auch schon bemerkenswert wenn sie auf
die Überstunden hinweisen und ich guck
mal auch gerade so nach Hessen wissen
Sie eigentlich wie viel der Überstunden
dadurch zustande kommen dass die
Bundespolizei die Ländern unterstützen
muss ja wo ist denn wo sind denn die
ganzen Polizeibeamten in Hessen warum
müssen die denn dahin fahren jedes
Wochenende haben sie die Überstunde
abgefahren hier auf dieses Konto gehen
also das ist unsere auch über die
Personalausstattung mal reden und
genauso verhält es sich hören Sie lieber
zu es ist nicht zu ihrem Nachteil
und genauso verhält es sich was
Befugnisse angeht die Länder hatten ja
gute Gründe und ich war zwar nicht dabei
weil ich höre Bayern sah irgendwie auch
dann hatten sie die vergessen also war
das irgendwie 15:1 im Bundestag gibt es
da jetzt so wehos ich will vor allen
Dingen aber einen Punkt noch mal
herausstellen weil ich leider nicht so
viel Redezeit habe um alle Geschichten
aufzuräumen weil das ist mir tatsächlich
wichtig und das meine ich wirklich ernst
und das nehmen Sie sich mal zu Herzen
weil wir vorhin eine Debatte übers
hinweisgeber-schutzgesetz geführt haben
und da steht im direkten zusammen
natürlich ist es gut und richtig so dass
das Vertrauen der Bevölkerung in die
Sicherheitsbehörden außerordentlich gut
ist aber ich wiederhole noch mal ein
Teil von gerade das ist nicht in allen
Bevölkerungsschichten gleich
unterhalten sie sich mal mit Familien
die eine Einwanderungsgeschichte haben
ich bin neulich auf einer Veranstaltung
gewesen nach dem Vorfall in Dortmund und
da sagen Ihnen Lehrerinnen und Lehrer
kleine Kinder haben Angst vor der
Polizei
nehmen sie das ernst und das können sie
nicht einfach wegwischen und sagen da
haben wir jetzt kein Problem oder nehmen
wir mal Durchschnittswert und da haben
wir nichts mit zu tun und spielen Sie
das um Himmels Willen nicht aus gegen
eine vermeintliche Position als sei das
gegen die Sicherheitsbehörden gerichtet
ich frage mich wirklich allen Ernstes wo
bleibt Landtag zur Abschaffung der
werbeauftragten
finden Sie das eigentlich das ist
Quatsch nichts anderes haben wir
eigentlich vor ein unabhängiges Gremium
für die Gegenargument sie müssten eine
Antrag einreichen sie wollen die
werbeauftragten abschaffen wenn sie
gegen polizeibeauftragte sind dass sie
haben sich offenbar gar nicht damit
beschäftigt das ist vollkommener Unsinn
zum Thema Kennzeichnungspflicht ich bin
gelernter Kriminalbeamter wissen Sie
eigentlich dass jeder Kriminalbeamter
bei Ermittlungsakten auch gegen die
organisierte Kriminalität mit Vor- und
Nachname in Ermittlungsakte steht ist
ihnen das eigentlich klar wir reden doch
hier nur über pseudonymisierte
Kennzeichen versuchen sie ja nicht die
ganze Polizei zu verunsichern
dass sich das Thema
Sicherheitsüberprüfung ist angesprochen
worden also was ich sagen will wir wir
müssen natürlich weiter dafür sorgen
dass das Vertrauen auch in allen Teilen
der Bevölkerung so groß ist wie ist das
im Durchschnitt ist das ist leider
Gottes noch ein Problem und dazu tun wir
ein ganzes Bündel von unterschiedlichen
Maßnahmen ich selbst habe eine gerade zu
abwegige Diskussion mit Horst Seehofer
darüber geführt ob wir den Wissenschaft
verbieten dürfen irgendwie die Polizei
zu untersuchen da kann ich mich noch
sehr gut daran erinnern also wir tun
sehr sehr viel um einerseits natürlich
die personelle Situation gut
ausgestatten es ist alles schon auch
unter anderem von kamen weg und anderen
gesagt worden technische Ausstattung die
Mittel sind aufgerüstet worden und
natürlich stehen wir mit allem was wir
haben hinter unseren Sicherheitsbehörden
und ich bin froh dass die
bundesinnenministerin auch dazu ein sehr
modernes
bundespolizeigesetz vorlegen wird
frohe Weihnachten
so liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
grüße sie alle und darf dann die
Aussprache schließen wir kommen zum
Antrag der Fraktion der cdu/csu auf
Drucksache 48/81 die Fraktion der
cdu/csu wünscht Abstimmung in der Sache
die Fraktionen SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und FDP wünschen Überweisung und zwar
federführend an den Ausschuss für
Inneres und Heimat und mit beratend an
den Rechtsausschuss wir stimmen
natürlich wieder zuerst über den Antrag
auf Ausschuss Überweisungen ab ich frage
deshalb wer stimmt für die beantragte
Überweisung
das ist spd-bündnis 90 die Grünen FDP
und AFD wer stimmt da gigan das sind die
linke und die cdu/csu Enthaltung keine
damit ist die Überweisung beschlossen
und wir stimmen heute über den Antrag
auf Drucksache 48/81 in der Sache nicht
ab